c'est ici que marc babeau puise toute sa
force sur le terrain familial où vivent
ses parents ses frères et soeurs et où
leurs enfants au milieu de la nature où
il aime aussi se ressourcer quand il a
su qu'il avait un cancer il ne pouvait
donc pas se laisser abattre
il avait une grosse heure à la poitrine
négligé depuis 4 ou 5 ans et des
douleurs aux lombaires et aux cervicales
commence à me dire mais avec des thèmes
techniques un génie des termes
techniques là mais c'est quoi exactement
cinq ans et on dit merci mon sentiment
très à cheval blanc cancer du sein je me
suis dit je ne me lève pas des soins
machin voix de l'histoire
son compagnon de route à ce moment là a
été son beau frère il a tout partagé
avec lui chaque étape de son parcours de
soin de quoi renforcer encore une
complicité de toujours entre les deux
hommes j'ai vainement banal alors que je
sais que dans le fond c'est très très
dur et c'est très supportable du coup
j'ai pas j'ai gardé la tête haute
et puis j'étais avec lui comme comme si
on a les bonnes sorties normal j'ai pas
pris la tête pendant parlait même pas de
ça on parlait de la la nature de tout ce
qu'on voit s le trajet rigoler avec le
chauffeur on n'a pas parlé de maladies
pas dont négative mais tout de même
la nouvelle du cancer du sein a été pour
le moins déstabilisante au départ quel
pourcentage peut avoir comme les femmes
atteintes du cancer du sein
il a fallu passer par la radiothérapie
et la chimiothérapie les eaux étaient
atteints par des métastases
les douleurs les difficultés à
s'alimenter en une année mark perd 36 kg
imaginez vous que je faisais 96 kg est
un beat google et là j'ai fini les soins
je faisais 60 kg même une fois je me
suis regardé dans un miroir
bon ben vous fini le début non mais on
va voir pour le décide on a repris le
dessus
aujourd'hui il pèse 86 kg et apprécie
chaque petite victoire sur la vie chaque
nouveau pas vers l'autonomie qu'il a
connu auparavant
et quand il a un petit souci voilà
désormais ce qu'il se dit je me dis que
la vie ne s'arrête pas là
mais si on analyse tout si je suis il
faut toujours aller en haut on a
quelqu'un de merveilleux qui veillent
sur nous